the first time i i manifest my desire to
become a professional
mixed martial art athlete everybody
doubt me
just not even i'm not talking about the
ufc just to become a professional
fighter everybody doubt me
and i became a
i became a professional fighter i had
few amateur fight i won them all then i
i fought my first fight in in montreal i
won and i became a professional
then i i told people that i wanted to
fight in ufc everybody doubt me again so
it's a normal thing
so i worked my way up i beat a few guys
then i
at the time uh pete spratt was uh
just knocked knocked out robbie lawler
with leg kick and
the person who was my agent at the time
did a great move uh for me so he brought
peace pratt and montreal to fight me
pete spratt came to montreal and i
believe
he didn't know who i was so he thought
that he was coming to collect an easy
paycheck and i and i end up beating him
so that gave me the opportunity to fight
in ufc
then after i was in ufc i wanted to
become champion of the world you know
but matt hughes was there and he seems
invincible at the time so
everybody doubt me again
and i became world champion and after
when you when i was world champion i
wanted to be
i was competing against other world
champion of other weight class
for
the title you know for the legacy and
everything so i was not no longer
competing against my opponent i was you
know as a competitor you always you you
never wanted to be you never want to be
satisfied because when satisfaction is
the death you know when you're satisfied
you better retire because it's over so
always i have to find motivation what
you can have more i want more don't be
satisfied in life so i wanted to be
like the best you know i was always
competing you know like to become the
best and and you know of course people
doubt doubt you all the time every time
you say something that it's outside of
the norm of the normality and when i say
there there's nothing normal but i'm
talking about
when you
you manifest your desire to do something
that
takes special attribute to to to succeed
or that is something that is hard to to
do it's for sure you're gonna always
have people that doubt you it's so
strange that people don't
they don't lean into supporting like
people that love you too yeah even
people that love me used to doubt me and
i believe i i you need to use that
as a positive positive thing as a
motivation to prove them wrong yeah so
for me that that was the thing when
someone doubt me nothing gave me more
there's more energy because i want to
prove him wrong i want to look at him in
the face and say hey you see
i got you man i did it